you know it's crazy bro i knew gazi for
like four years we ain't never talked
about no business we had one
conversation about some business this
was last january we always text about
just regular [ __ ] like what's up hope
all is well you know yeah doing your
thing it's always
regular conference we never text about
being i'm sure if i had to hit him about
some business he probably would have
eventually but you know it just be
regular [ __ ] but like one thing about
guys that man put a lot of opportunity
in detroit michigan he has
literally he did he did i can't can't
nobody can't nobody front that [ __ ]
take that away from him he did way more
for detroit
than anybody on them as far as a museum
other than barry gordy
that's some real [ __ ] that's a fact
can't nobody that's a fact and he's
there a lot like it ain't even about
but i'm saying bottom line is barry
gordy and guys he did a lot for the
detroit
music's culture period that's a fact
that's that's that's fair that ain't
even argue we can't even argue that's
not even the up for debate and i'm not
with empire and that's not up for debate
i'm a real [ __ ] that's just the truth